[Music]
protests have become increasingly
frequent and widespread in Iran
throughout the past several years what
does Iran's leadership think about this
trend and what does it mean for the
future of the regime Iran's supreme
leader has described generational
turnover and declining support for the
Islamic Republic as an existential
threat to its survival he broadly terms
this phenomenon as a cultural softw that
he believes the US and its allies are
waging on Iranian youth through media
outlets and other mediums what's the
regime's solution more indoctrination
propaganda efforts targeting Iranian
youth Iran began building an
infrastructure to bolster Pro regime
sentiments following the 2009 protest
wave and has reinforced this
infrastructure in recent years the
regime uses propaganda surveillance
technology and other tools to identify
and punish anti-regime actors and purges
moderates and reformist leaders from key
roles within the regime recent protests
however have demonstrated that the
supreme leader vision is fundamentally
incompatible with that of the Iranian
populations Iranian youth are unlikely
to be plated by anything other than
meaningful reform so the regime software
strategy is doomed to fail the question
is
when what do you think Iran's leadership
will do about the increasing number of
protests let us know in the comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like for our Scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to like And
subscribe for more research and videos
from
AI